hello everyone and welcome to a final
round game between Magnus cross and
another Rebecca dusatrov it is the
Armageddon game but most of the moves
that were played in classical will be
repeated in Armageddon uh let me just
quickly uh change the number on the
little robot there that's already on the
little robot there we go uh and yes as
uh as the title suggests this is uh not
the worst tournament Magnus Carlsen ever
played in terms of how uh a much rating
he lost he lost 18 rating points this
tournament there is one tournament uh
from 2015 also was played in Norway at
where Magnus lost 23 rating points but
in terms of not winning a single game uh
or rather not winning a single classical
game because the Magnus won seven
Encounters of the nine that he had uh it
we we have to go back uh like 16 years
and 72 tournaments um for Magnus Carlsen
to actually play a tournament where he
did not a classical tournament where he
did not win a single classical game so
that's uh okay he did take some time off
and it's a bit of a different tournament
it's it's a hybrid wherein every year
classical game is followed by an
Armageddon game so most players could
also just be trying to get a draw to
reach Armageddon but still not a single
win that is that is pretty harsh uh so
uh let's see what happened in the final
round he's facing another back and most
of the moves uh they played up until
move 20 will be exactly the same as they
played in classical games so if you
haven't seen the classical you will also
see what happens so E4 we have a
repetition here from the classical uh
the The Rue Lopez sorry uh Knight to
another Lopez uh the uh Peter of Defense
the real Lopez was in the previous game
Knight captures an E5 accepting uh going
for the classical variation Ponte D6
Knight to F3 and now Knight captures on
e4 so uh very standard stuff here D3
Knight to F6 and pawn to D4 we have Pawn
to D5 and the bishop to D3 uh we have
Bishop to D6 and now Queen to E2 with
check and the queen to E7 is the most
standard reply here but another big goes
for Bishop to E6 he wants to keep the
Queens on the board and interestingly
Magnus already had this position against
Fabiano Corona in the green gitches
classic in 2017 where he played C4 and
that game ended in a draw but here he
goes for Knight the G5 as he did in the
classical game uh Queen to E7 with
Knight captures 96 F captures on E6 and
just spawn to C3 we have Castles by both
players and now Pawn to E5 another big
strikes in the center as Magnus allowed
it the captures uh and now there is a
game where Bishop captures and E5 was
played but here we have Queen captures
on E5 which would be a completely new
move uh or rather a completely new game
but they already played this exact line
in classical so Queen captures on E5 you
have to trade or do something about this
Checkmate threat uh Magnus trades Bishop
captures and now Knights the D2 We have
Knight B to D7 Knight to F3 and now
Bishop back to D6 not allowing this
trade to happen Pawn to G3 and pawn to
C6 now we have King to G2 Rook 8 to E8
and now Pawn to A4 uh we have Pawn to A5
and now we have Knight to D4 and this is
the first new move from the classical
game in the classical game okay they've
reached this position in Armageddon uh
through a different move order but
Magnus played a rook to B1 here in the
the classical game here he plays Knights
to D4 and now it is truly as of move 20
that we have a completely new game so
okay Bishop to C5 let's see how the game
continues Bishop to F5 by Magnus with
Bishop captures and D4 uh C Captain D
for and now Rook to F7 preparing to
double up on the D file so uh the Knight
pair against The Bishop's pair that
plays on both sides of the board and
it's a pretty open position so the best
repair should be a little bit better but
still it's Armageddon with Bishop to D3
Knight to f8 and now uh Bishop Teddy to
everyone knows the shorter the time
controls the trickier those night
bastards are Knights the E6 and now
Bishop to C3 just defending the pawn on
D4 so for the moment this dark Square
Bishop is a pawn uh we'll we'll see if
Magnus can figure out how to optimize
its strength Bishop Bishop to C3
followed by Pawn to B6 Rook after E1 and
now Rook after E7 doubling up on the E
file Pawn to B4 now is not messing
around obviously eight characters Bishop
captures attacks the rook and now Rook
the A7 puts pressure on the A4 pawn
bishop back to C3 now again guarding the
D4 pawn and King to F7 we have Rook e to
B1 putting pressure on the B6 spawn and
Knight to D7 defending that pawn with
Ponte H4 Bishop to C2
uh sorry uh first a rook um eat A8
putting pressure on the A4 pawn and now
Bishop to C2 defending that pawn we have
Pawn to H5 not allowing Magnus to
further Advance those King side pawns
and rooked back to E1 now preparing to
go after the Knight with a move like
Bishop to F5 so Knight to F6 and now
Rook uh e uh a back to B1 going after
the B6 pawn and the best way to defend
this is actually just put the Rook on
the B file it looks like something you
don't want to do because if you play uh
for example Rook to B7 then A5 can be
played now you can't capture because the
Rook would be hanging but you can play
Rook 8 e B8 and now after A6 you just
bring it back so that's how you how you
do it however another went for a pawn
sacrifice he played Pawn to B5 a
captures B captures C captures and B5
and now Magnus doesn't capture the pawn
he instead first threatens the Knight on
E6 Bishop to F5 we have rooked a
defending and now again not capturing
and B5 Magnus goes for Bishop to B4 and
Magnus had something beautiful in mind
when he played his Bishop to B4 move the
problem is he missed the one move by
another back Norberg plays Knight
captures on D4 Rook captures 98 and here
Magnus probably thought that another big
will play King capture Sunny it because
if he does this then he is very very
close to Lost to give you an example uh
Bishop C5 attacks the rook and the
Knight and once you move the Rook to
defend the Knight now you play Rook to
E1 with check and this is Rook D1 check
is the key move uh point is that if you
go to d8 Bishop to B6 is made in one uh
the bishop pair doing a fine job here
The Rook controlling the E file so you
would have to go all the way uh to the f
file but now Rook the E7 comes also with
Chuck King to Jade and now Bishop to G6
and good luck getting out of this the
bishop here The Rook on the seventh rank
the dark Square Bishop uh very hard to
imagine that you can survive this in at
lower time formats but a little bit
tricked him he played Knight capture 78
and now you really don't have all that
much you don't have that key Rook the E1
check after Bishop to C5 so you don't
even Magnus doesn't even play it because
after Bishop C5 Rook A4 uh what do you
play your Bishop is hanging here you
have to move it back and then Knight to
F6 uh Norbit would be perfectly fine so
instead Bishop to D3 and now Knight back
to F6 no lyrics says I'm very happy with
my position nothing to worry about here
Bishop back to C3 threatens the Knight
again and Rook to A3 now goes for the
for the bishop pair uh Bishop capture
Sandy for Rook campus and D3 and Bishop
to B6 now with Knight to G4 now
preparing to put pressure on the F2 Pawn
but okay for the moment you don't care
as the bishop is guarding that F2 Pawn
Rook captures on B5 Magnus finally goes
after the pawn Rook D2 and King to F3
now uh Pawn to G6 and now Bishop to C5
we have D4 and King the E4 and here we
have Knight back to F6 the point is if
you go for Knight captures and have to
do with Chuck King D5 uh it can be
played of course but it's um it's just a
draw you you cannot Advance the pawn D3
just Bishop captures King captures and
now King T4 attacks the pawn pawn is
pushed forward the road goes behind the
pass pawn and no promoting of the past
Pawn for you sir
so instead Knight to F6 would check even
though okay not Rebecca could go for
this because a draw in Armageddon is um
you know equals a win for him uh but
both of them were extremely low on time
King F3 Knight back to G4 Rook to B6 and
now Rook captures an F2 with check King
to E4 uh Knight to F6 with check King
captures and D for now so equal material
Bishop against the Knight basically Rook
to D2 check King E3 Rook to D5 and
Bishop to D4 now it's merely a matter of
who's faster and who will make a second
to last mistake Rook the five King to D3
Rook F3 check King C4 Rook F5 and now
Rook the B7 with check uh King G8 Rook
D7 King to f8 and now Rook day seven you
only have one second increment so you
cannot waste more than a second making
your move King the G8 Bishop to E3
Knight to G4 and Bishop to G5 with King
to f8 Bishop to F4 King to G8 and King
to D4 now we have King to a fade Bishop
to G5 King to G8 and rooked A8 with
check a couple of checks in order to get
a bit more time on the clock King G8
King to C for King to f8 Bishop D2 King
to G8 Bishop to C3 King to f8 Bishop G7
check King j8 and now Bishop back to D4
King f8 Rook to G7 finally going after
the G6 pawn and uh another book should
just push it G5 and now after uh this
gets traded captures captures and
captures this is still a draw but he
went Knight to E5 with check and the
Magnus says alright I will take that
extra pawn bishop captures real captors
and Rook captures on G6 King to F7 and
now Rook to D6 now Magnus is up a pawn
and okay still objectively a draw but he
will push this for a win rookie three
Rook to D3 and now Rook D5 Rook to D5
again with a rook going after the G3
pawn and Rook G5 defending King F6 and
now King to D4 you have to bring your
king some uh somehow closer to the
defense of the G3 pawn and then you will
be able to capture on H5 so that would
be ideal Rook day 3 and this is the
losing move but you know seconds on the
clock King to E4 Rook e4cha King to F3
rookie three checking to G2 rookie ducha
King to H3 now the pawn is defended and
the A5 H5 phone can be captured The Rook
A7 Rook captures an H5 now Magnus up two
connected past pawns uh this is most
certainly winning uh King G6 Rook G5
King F6 Rook to G for King F5 Pawn to H5
Magna starts advancing the pass pawn and
now Rook to A1 and interestingly you do
have two connected past pawns but there
is only one winning move here for Magnus
uh so feel free to pause the video and
try to spot this most elusive idea while
I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations uh on spotting
this this is not an easy move to find
because even Magnus missed it and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook the G8 uh and the point
is that Black's only defense pretty much
is Rook to H1 check and after King to G2
now you cannot capture an H5 if you
capture an H5 then G for check picks up
the rook and it's game over and uh if
you can't pick up the pawn then G4 check
is coming then the pawns are nicely
defended and you are again winning the
problem here with Rook the B4 it's a
similar idea and Magnus spots this of
course now Rook to H1 check will be met
with King to G2 and you again cannot
capture because of G4 with check the
problem is uh Rook to D1 and now again
you you cannot Advance
any of the pawns I mean you can play G4
that's not a problem but after King to
G5 you will not be able to uh to kick
away that King from G5 so instead King
to F2 was played now comes King to G5
Rook the H4 you have to defend the H5
pawn and now King the H6 we have King to
F3 Rook the D3 check King to G4 Rook to
D4 with check King to H3 and here now
that we've played Rook to D3 and the
Magnus uh uh he he knocked over some
pieces and then he quickly played King
to G2 but before he pressed the clock
his time ran out uh and it was in this
position basically after Rook to D3
unmove 92 that Magnus Carlsen lost on
time but also the position is
objectively a draw it's one of the those
uh cases where yes you are up two pawns
but this is a draw uh point is that um
okay even if we continue the game with
magnus's King G2 which is one of the
engine uh strongest moves uh you cannot
continue pushing those pawns you cannot
move the Rook from the h file because
you lose this Pawn if you try Pawn to G
for just King G5 how are you playing
this now wherever you put the Rook
checks are coming and then of course you
will lose the G4 pawn and if if you
don't do this you could try a rook dh1
to get the Rook into the game somehow
but still you have to guard this spawn
then just Rook A4 and I mean you can't
move the Rook because you lose this you
can play G4 because you defended that
square and if the king starts marching
forward then we of course start checking
the white king so one of the rare cases
where the two uh two connected pass
pawns equals a draw
uh but yeah very nicely done by another
back holding Magnus to draw In classical
and also beating him in Armageddon and
like I said okay here we can check out
the standings as we haven't seen him in
the previous one Hikaru wins the
tournament he defeated Fabiano caruana
in the final round so
overshadowing him by half a point if you
haven't seen it it's my previous video
do check it out and then gookish in
third place absolutely incredible
performance with 14 and a half Anish in
fourth place with 13 Wesley song 12 and
a half Magnus Carlsen in sixth place
with 11 and a half and like I said uh
Magnus only lost the first round game uh
to Fabi and the last round to another in
Armageddon okay he lost the Fabian
classical the other seven uh seven
rounds he won all of them in Armageddon
that's why he is so so far behind uh
Shakir 11 points uh yeah alireza uh ten
and a half in eighth place uh so not the
not the greatest result for alireza
another second to last with nine points
and aryantari in last place with six
points but he does have the final laugh
as he has defeated alireza furyja in the
Final Round In classical chess so very
good for him and yeah here are the the
live ratings
um uh like I said Magnus losing 18
points so the the only worse tournament
that he had where he lost 23 points was
uh in 2015 also in Norway uh but uh you
know other than that not really and in
terms of not winning a single classical
game okay if you counted this as a
classical tournament this is sort of a
hybrid because every classical game is
followed by Armageddon but yeah last
time he did uh not win a single
classical game 16 years ago and 72
tournaments ago so absolutely wild stuff
uh okay like I said he did take some
rest for from chess he came back he said
okay I still remember how to play but
you know it's not gonna be it's not
gonna be you just sit and you you
destroy everyone you will still need to
prepare for the tournament and take it
very seriously but yeah the big winner
sikaru world number two uh with plus 12
if Fabiano core one a world number three
with plus eight okay Ding and nipple not
playing anything other is a minus nine
uh Anish and the Wesley also on plus
three and plus four uh good Cash Plus
Eight he finishes the tournament with
2744 absolutely incredible going uh
close to that 27.50 he finishes it as
number 13 in the world also shock they
are on plus two uh mvl playing some
different terminal with minus five uh
and uh way Yi also playing some other
tournament but doing incredibly well he
is uh up on plus 7.8 so yeah a little
bit about the the live rating so hope
you enjoyed that as well and yeah I
really hope you enjoyed the games and
this short coverage of the Norway chess
2023 we'll see we'll see what happens in
the next one uh but this one uh you know
this one belongs to Hikaru Nakamura also
a current world number two uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank David Kimura an
anonymous person David guzparian Ricky
Johnson and father for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and everything else that
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day